the coronavirus has forced the nfl to  move sunday's raiders game  league officials move that game against  tampa bay from sunday night at five  o'clock  to sunday afternoon at one o'clock the  nfl did not want the prime time slot  empty  if the game is canceled raiders  offensive tackle trent brown was put on  the covet reserve list with a positive  test earlier this week  several other players were held out of  practice this week as a precaution  now today the nfl said the raiders have  had no additional positive tests so that  is some good news  the eights now sports team will make  sure to keep you posted on all things  raiders so stay with  them and be sure to catch the raiders  pregame live show right here on channel  eight is every sunday morning at eight  a.m it's a great show  and don't forget to share your pictures  and videos with us cheering on our las  vegas raiders  send them to pix 8newsnow.com and we'll  put you on the show we'll